thanks to the organizers for this kind
invitation it's a pleasure to be our and
once again talk a little bit more about
enhancer gene interactions so this has
been work largely done by my postdoc
Jean wrong I actually collaborated with
him while I was a research scientist and
the Lotus Colossus lab so we've been
doing this for about a year and a half
now and I think the results we have a
reasonably interesting and we've been
sort of working on validating a bunch of
these these interactions using crisper
cast line so i'll give you a broad
overview of sort of a new probabilistic
model we have developed to try to info
and answer gene interactions it's just
from chromatin data and expression data
across many diverse types and tissues
the goal is to infer cell-type specific
interactions and then to try to use
these interactions to info interesting
hypotheses about target genes that may
be affected by a non-coding g was
variants so that's basically the theme
of the talk so we're going to focus on
this particular data set which is a data
from the roadmap epigenomics project and
the encode project and this was
published sometime last year basically
it's a really nice data set with epi
genomes and transcript dose of about 127
different cell types tissues and cell
lines in combination ranging from a
variety of adult tissues fetal tissues
iips ES cells and differentiated cells
and we also include a few and code cell
lines within this within this set so
it's basically a nice collection of 127
cell types each of these cell types and
tissues have at least six key histone
modifications open chromatin sa is a
subset of them have an open chromatin
assays DNA methylation and gene
expression so that's basically the data
set so one way we decided to integrate
this data was to essentially try to
learn these hidden Markov models using
the chromhmm method and what it does is
as you know different combinations of
marks often define different classes of
elements so promoters for example will
have tri methyl and oscillation and
answers will have
oscillation and motor methylation and so
on so chromium basically walks across
the genome loans in hmm that that loans
these states representing different
combinations or marks now you can do
this for a single cell type what we did
is we order to sort of learn a joint
model across all the hundred
twenty-seven cell types so we did a
virtual concatenation of these of each
of these cell types and we learned a
single hmm across the board so nice
thing is now you have a joint model
across all cell types all the states
sort of align with each other and so on
and so with the five core marks that we
had a capo dimethyl mono methyl okay 36
tri methyl k9 trimethylene k twice and
time Ethel we learned a 15 state model
the number of states is of course you
know you pick it out of your hat but
this was something that was pretty
reasonable with these 15 states we
capture broad classes of elements like
active promoters flanking DSS regions
transcribed regions enhancer like states
a bunch of other kinds of
heterochromatin repeat states by violent
or poised states and then polycom
depressed elements so basically there
are a bunch of active largely active
chromatin states and a bunch of
repressed governance states so using
this strategy we can now essentially
take all the 127 cell types each row is
one of these cell types and I'm focusing
on one specific locus around the pax5
gene and I can color every position in
the genome based on the inferred state
in that cell type so you know we pick up
pretty nice dynamics of example pax5 is
as you expect highly yes violent state
mm-hmm i SAT with him this is bangkok by
violence because of gender identity or
you think that you have small taneously
the same
receiver agent both types of marks
that's a good question it depends I
guess because in some sometimes you see
by violence simply because it's allelic
by violence or her de Janerio cross
sells many of these are tissues so it
could even be more hydrogenous in that
case but we also have embryonic stem
cell 0 where violence has been shown to
be real no because it's a comment it's a
pretty heterogeneous set of things right
its tissue cell line cell types all
kinds of stuff so I'll just call it a
bivalent state and not care so much a
hood if either is exactly x 100 or not i
would generally just put that in sort of
a different class of elements and these
are largely and rich th1 cells that's
that's something we see so they probably
in some cases truly by one in other
cases alee likely or a cross cells any
other questions sorry i was looking at
the screen so yeah so you get this very
nice dynamics and we want to now start
using some of these dynamics to try to
infer essentially which distant elements
may be linked to which wich proximal
elements so you know Baxter gene shows
very nice cell type specifically
expressed in specific types of
lymphoblastoid lines and T cells and
then around it one I think interesting
feature is the sort of non-continuous
dynamics of the genome you have a region
right here that's highly cell
type-specific and right next to it
there's a gene for example that is super
ubiquitous so this kind of pretty
interesting it goes back to what I'll
show later is that the association's we
learned it in the hands and jeans
usually need not be proximal in fact we
often see an answer skipping the nearest
genes in terms of associations so going
forward one of the things we were able
to do is is is find a bunch of purity of
enhancers and these we define as
chromatin accessible sites so DNA speaks
in states that essentially annotated as
enhancers in at least one of these cell
types so we can take we obtain two
million such chromatin accessible
elements that fall in an answer like
states and at least one cell type and if
we take these as that's the columns in
this matrix and if you take the rows and
we essentially just cluster them back
every day so if you see yellow it means
the answers
active and why it it's inactive so you
just cluster this you actually see it
only nice modular dynamics right so we
pick up approximately 200 206 course
modules and if you take these modules
and just run like some kind of go
annotation enrichment engine like great
you actually pick up a pretty cell type
and tissue-specific or lineage-specific
go terms so for example this module that
is active in ES and IPS cells highly
enriched four terms in development
morphology immune enhancer that are
highly specifically active in t-cells
and b-cells are enriched for immune
response terms and so on so it indicates
that there's a sort of very nice modular
dynamics of an answer is you need
lineage-specific activity and rich for
linear specific functions now the key
question we weren't able to answer is
which enhancers associated with jeans
that's something you don't get easily
out of this analysis we had initially
done so John drawn basically try to work
on this and you know while we were at
MIT and now he's joined my lab as a post
or and we were trying to use an
unsupervised strategy to link these
enhancers two genes so as you all know
there are a variety of different
experimental methods for a saying
chromatin contact maps I just list a few
you're a high C and chia pet and and
these are generally good I mean they're
getting better over time but i would say
hi see still most high seed SS out there
other than for example the Lieberman
dataset which is really very nice
generally you know 10 KB fragments so
it's pretty low resolution chia pet on
the other hand is specific for the
proteins that you pull down with with
the chip gently the high costs require
millions of cells and one I think
central issue with high see that we've
seen and maybe you guys agree and like
no opinions is generally you know the
interactions that you can predict that
you can pick up from high sea maps
reliably tend to be these most stable
loops so the CDC has mediated stable
loops think about these dynamic enhancer
promoter contacts is much harder to
reliably call them from hi-c data even
if it's really deep so for example the
Lieberman you know folks find fifties
50,000 looping interactions and
depending on how you process the data
you can
learn more or less loops or interactions
but it definitely do not cover the
entire spectrum of an answer jeans and
so they don't really give you all the
information you need so there's only a
relatively low signal-to-noise in the
interesting region interesting sort of
interaction space which is these dynamic
and answered promoter contacts and
recently there have also been several
studies showing that 3d fish experiments
actually highly contradict I see so you
often see very nice proximal contact and
fish but you see nothing in the hi-c map
so there's lots of you know hi-c isn't
necessarily the ground proof yeah it's I
would say so I have a hypothesis that
most enhancer promoter interactions are
not like sticky in the sense there's
lots of there's a regulatory potential
and you need a certain maybe you put a
number of answers to kind of activate a
gene and you have an ensemble of an
answer that can dynamically loop back
and forth to promoters or not and that's
probably one of the reasons why you do
not see them as much in high C because
there is heterogeneity maybe across
cells and so on but that's just
hypothesis yeah that's a great question
but I think those are nice talk also at
Cold Spring other systems biology this
this year that really showed this
dramatic difference between like what
you see physically in microscopy and
things you just do not see in the IC
maps and we've tried also promising
strategies and I think others have tried
this too is very hard to pull out beyond
the CDC has loops a lot of the other
interactions you see are highly
reproducible across replicas and so on
so it's pretty difficult to get signal
from that and these are usually a you
know available only in a few cell types
so what are the strategies that folks
have used to kind of learn from other
kinds of data is an unsupervised
learning strategy where let's say you
given a matrix of genes in a bunch of
cell types you have so let's say RNA
seek expression data or DNA see
Commodores and then you have a bunch of
enhancers that you call
in the same cell types and you have some
other measure of an answer activity
let's say K formula methylation or dnas
then you can try to do some kind of
Association like testing framework so
you can do Pearson correlation or
something and then you could permute
these matrices and like a classical
association test link and answers to
genes so these are marginal association
test testing techniques and I think the
biggest problem generally is they're
highly underpowered because you
generally don't have many observations
you have just a few cell types and so
there are exponentially many sorry you
know you have a product of genes times
and answers that's the number of tests
you're trying to do and that
dramatically reduces your power others
of you supervise approaches where you
actually train on these high C or chia
pet maps a year or two years a recent
paper I think it's from Katie Polar's
group and I think one of the problems
with this approach is a journey the
training data is very sparse so for
example you pick up a few thousand
positive links that you could can call
confidently from hi-c and also these
links the features can often be cell
type-specific so it's pretty hard to
generalize across the board potentially
for lots of cell types so what we want
to do is really look at what the yeah by
links like for example hi-c interactions
or chia pet interactions right between
enhancers and promoters for example so
you know you'll have you'll have
positive links from from an assay and
then negative links that is things that
don't interact versus things that
interact so you'll have a binary
classification task or regression task
you've throw in a bunch of features and
try to predict so it's a supposed
learning task right so what we want to
do is sort of also go back to the basic
assumption of what kind of relationship
and answers and genes actually have are
they for example then you're linearly
correlated across cell types or do they
have nonlinear behaviors if I got me so
very often so this is a real interaction
that we see in in cd4 t-cells supported
by chia pet and various other essays and
an answer linking to the TV CC promoter
and if you just plot the gene expression
data again see an answer activity you
see in most cell types the genus off and
the answer is off so it's just a cloud
of noise
right and then you have some cell types
in which they're both on other cell
types in which the the gene is on but
the enhancers off and other cell types
worthy and answers are on the gene is
off right so it's clearly not a linear
relationship it's pretty on off and the
same gene can be potentially activated
by other enhancers that an answer can
potentially activate other genes so it's
kind of hinting that that particular
strategy so if you use like linear
correlation like methods like
association matrix then you kind of get
killed pretty bad so this this this
promoter this interaction which is
actually really strong in the GOP data
only as a correlation of 0 point four so
we want to kind of bed develop a
slightly different way of associating
and answers of genes sort of potentially
a nonlinear metric okay so we were kind
of get around this issue of enhancer
activity being sparse and nonlinear we
want to build many to many maps and try
to learn cell type-specific links rather
than assuming that a link is invariant
and sort of capturing an answer in gene
activity across cell types and
developing some sort of linear
correlation Association metric so this
is the strategy we used we try to build
this hierarchical probabilistic model
the basic idea is you start off with
these two matrices of activity gene
activity in an answer activity and you
first start by learning modular behavior
so like I showed you answers have this
pretty nice modular behavior so you can
take advantage of that and learn sort of
a latent variable space there instead of
linking individual enhances to in
individual genes you first learn modules
of enhancers and modules of jeans right
then you try to link modules to modules
so now you have much fewer variables
that you need to link right the latent
variables once you learnt the links
between the modules then you go into
these links so into these linked modules
and then you try to dissect which
answers a link to it genes is sort of a
hierarchical approach okay and for this
we use this sort of a mixed membership
model there are two components this
model the first is a mixed membership
model which allows enhancers to
probabilistically belong to multiple
modules okay and this is we use are
pretty simple that alone makes
membership model called ID a latent
additional allocation which allows an
answer and jeans to provost Utley belong
to modules so there are two main
parameters you need to think about the
first is what
because the fractional probability so
this is a probability of observing the
caith module in the teat cell type okay
so this tells you the the importance of
the module in a specific cell type and
then the second probability is the
enhancer module membership okay so
that's the probability of the an answer
given the module okay the latent modules
EK so this is sort of sort of
hierarchical topic model where you
assume for example it's based on this
document model so for example documents
you know can be represented as mixtures
of topics hidden topics and topics are
mixtures of words right and so in this
case our cell types are like documents
are enhancers and jeans are like words
so we have this kind of mixed membership
clustering model on the enhancer matrix
and also on the gene matrix so the idea
of this this particular piece of the
model is to learn the module structure
in the announcer matrix and in the gene
matrix so we have two such models when
the second component tries to link these
together okay so the basic idea is you
now have these these module fraction
probability so let's say we learnt the
enhancer modules right remember we have
this parameter that tells us how
important that module is in each tissue
right so that's this similarly for the
gene modules we have this probability of
gene module being active in different
issues right so you can think of a
simple metric whereby if the gene module
and the enhancer module both have
similar fractional probability profiles
then they are more likely to be linked
right so that's the intuition behind
this and so we can try to learn a matrix
a pairwise matrix between all and
handsome modules of gene modules that
captures this this posterior probability
of a gene module being linked to an
answer module okay and so a little bit
of math but the way we try to do this is
rather than looking for a global
correlation again across all cell types
we focus on the cell type that has the
highest module fractional probability
for the announcer module so for a
particular answer module let's pick the
cell type that has the highest
fractional probability of membership and
then for that particular cell type just
focusing on that cell type we let all
the gene modules compete forgetting sort
of correlated to the enhancer module
case
all the gene modules are competing to
try to link to the announcer module in
the cell type in which the answer module
is most active and we use sort of her
yeah somehow your model yes works in the
energy you know I think you're actually
in an answer then this assumption that
they will correlate over cell types is
in a won't work so the question is do
you fight i doing how much this is
really happening in the day yeah i mean
like i showed you i mean actually we're
not assuming they're independent because
we are explicitly forcing them to go
through this module structure right so
in fact there's a lot of dependence in
their activity space right so that's I
guess then I should rephrase and say
that you seen this to enhancer modules
are independent in your model where you
try to now tied into the gene movie yes
so both of them to work in order for
gene module to turn up and down then you
would see when you make your connections
no you can actually link i'll show you
later but that's that's not an
assumption we allow any enhancer module
to link to any gene module so we
condition on if you take every enhancer
module check which cell type it is most
active in through this probability and
then we allow all gene modules to
compete to get access to it so we will
learn a probabilistic link then we go to
the next and answer module and we again
learn this so you can have an answer
modules linked to multiple gene what is
in fact that's what we find okay so
effectively we are able to learn this AI
j parameter that captures there at the
linking probability between a nicer than
jeans and i can give you more details on
this diffusion method it's it's pretty
complicated so i don't have enough time
to get into it but it allows you
basically to think about looking at the
enhancer module fractional probability
and the gene module fractional
probability what is the likelihood that
you know the answer module can diffuse
across the diagonal versus diffuse out
of the square and if it if it's more
likely to diffuse out of the diagonal
then it has a higher likelihood of
interacting with the gene module that's
basically the idea so this is an
intuitive feel for it
already picked the cell type for which
module is most probable oh yes you have
already picked the cell type using
then we pick the cell type but all the
gene modules are competing so each of
these points so the enhancer module
probability is fixed but the gene module
probability switches right so all of
those gene modules are in this map and
they are trying to diffuse across the
diagonal and the one that diffuses more
quickly is the one that's more likely to
be associated with the gene module so
they all compete in that sense it makes
sense so we can fit this model jointly
instead of learning the module structure
on the jeans and the enhancers
separately and then linking we can use a
single sort of joint Gibbs sampling
approach that learns the latent module
structure for the enhancers launch it
for the genes then computes the linking
probability and then re updates the the
module assignment for the announcers in
the genes and continues is iteratively
until the models converge ok so you
simultaneously learn the module
structure use them to learn the linking
and then use the linking to update the
module structure and so on so it's an
iterative process from this you can then
compute the probability that any
announcers linked to any gene in a given
tissue by simply combining these
parameters so basically you have the
probability of enhancer I belonging to
module k alright you have the
probability of module k being active in
tissue t then you have the linking
probability of an answer module k to
gene module h and similarly you have the
membership probability of gene J in gene
module H and probability of gene module
H being active in in the tissue tee so
when you combine all of this in
marginalize out or the Lancer modules
and gene modules you can effectively get
a probability for every gene linked to
every enhancer condition on a specific
tissue yes that's how you get the
probability now just getting the
property is not enough because you need
to actually find statistically
significant links and so now what we do
is once we have all these PR these
probabilities of associations between
genes and enhancers we focus on about 1
megabytes base domains around genes and
then we compute a large distribution for
the linking probabilities by basically
shuffling either the enhancer matrix of
the G matrix right and so you can you
can compute another it's not null
distribution of these properties of
linking
and then you can compute a p-value and
an FDR for any specific link yes this
model up to this point is not used all
the boxing no only at this stage reduces
proximity fraction of what you get falls
into these stuff because in principle
you could get that answers and spelling
absolutely this is mostly a choice we
make because of power constraints right
so we have so the modules are helping us
constrain things now because we don't
try to link every answer to every gene
it's just sort of module to module
linking right but within enhancer
modules and gene modules we still have
quite a few and answers and jeans and
you know hi-c deer and other data show
that most links are tend to be within
tabs or at least neighboring tabs so
which is going to focus on distal links
but not very very long range link so we
definitely don't learn inter chromosomal
interactions for example or eighty
percent of your more so this is this is
using all the enhancers and all the
genes but it is it is focusing on links
that are within that distance constraint
right so those links would potentially
be yeah but those links would
potentially be a small fraction of the
total number of links maybe ten percent
yeah
I'm co-regulated large groups autograph
tissue-specific express jeans and me
specific active and so within those no I
don't know if you start now
marginalizing over the different
associations could you really pick out
within those groups not with specific
enhancer links to which gene or is this
more or less than just driven blow out
by it in the end after all I just look
at what are the clothes once together in
saucier that's that's not exactly what
it does in fact it is able to pick up
these interesting like a looping across
jeans and things like that so it's not
just looking for proximal things i'll
show you some analysis showing how it
compares to nearest gene and so on a
second yes you have to predefine that
yeah absolutely like any other
clustering method but we play with these
parameters to see what gives us the best
i'll surely not exactly so we pick up 61
and answer modules and 65 gene modules
okay across all the cell types that's
correct yeah so this is what the linking
structure looks like and like like you
are asking you can see how multiple
modules can be linked to multiple
modules so it doesn't necessarily force
any single and answer wanted to link
only to one gene module you can have
many too many linking and again when we
learn the module structure if you just
take their modules themselves and do go
annotations they be captured only nice
linear specific terms for the enhancer
modules we also do that for the gene
module so there is this kind of
indicating that the module learning is
sort of working reasonably well because
picking up tissue-specific Alinea
specific activity terms this is just
showing the the number of enhancers s
cell types in which an enhancer module
has sort of high activity you can see it
sometimes goes up to 10 this is the an
answer module two cell types sort of
cessation matrix similarly for gene
modules the 65 gene modules is again
showing you that gene modules can be
active in multiple cell types and not
just one cell type or anything that sort
even though the linking right was
focusing on a single cell type the mode
we can still be active in multiple cell
types this is the answer to gene module
linking probability and again yes
these are gene modules is not jeans
right so that there are there are rarely
modules that are active in all the cell
types I mean there's probably one module
right which is which is the main like
the ubiquitous module it probably has a
yeah I mean I cut it off that is there
are many more sometimes I just want to
show their this distribution so this is
the announcer gene module linking
probability and here you can see again
that multiple and answer modules can
link to multiple genes okay so an FDR of
one percent we pick up about 250,000
statistically significant enhancer to
gene links linking one 32,000 and
answers to 15,000 genes ok that's
basically what we can learn obviously
there are many more links but given the
power we have that's basically what we
pick up so I just want to show you
quickly some how much time do I have all
right so we of course you want to
validate these links against some
experimental data so these are just a
ucs on hi-c links chia pet links and
eqtls for different cell types and
tissues so these are you cease but i
also have a you PRC oh sorry precision
recall curves which are more relevant
for this kind of unbalanced training one
of the reasons I I don't mind showing a
you see for this kind of data is because
each of these data types have pretty
high false negative rates because we use
pretty stringent thresholds so the
negatives are not as well defined as the
positives this is just showing that so
this this shows that we have good
agreement across the board for different
types of essays including eqtls this is
showing the tissue specificity of the
predicted links so if we take our
predicted links and we look at hi-c in
different cell types co-parent different
cell types and so on and we look for
enrichment of the predict the
tissue-specific predicted links with
respect to tissue-specific hi-c then you
start seeing pretty nice tissue-specific
enrichment so h1 links that we predict a
much more enriched in h1 hi-c then and
other cell types okay so this is sort of
validating to some extent the
tissue-specific of the predictions
same way for you pls and for cheap and
interactions we have some immune cells
and breast cancer these are precision
recall curves comparing to other methods
and again you notice how the position we
call is actually pretty terrible across
the board for all methods and again this
may not necessarily be because the
methods suck or it could be because of
methods suck including ours but I think
it's more to do with the data just
having not being an actual gold standard
the positives are pretty verifying the
negatives not so much but either way rld
a method actually does generally better
precision we call them most of the
methods we haven't compared to the
latest two of the latest methods which
we are going to add to this pretty soon
these are some properties is the long
range and answer gene network so the key
thing you'll notice is generally each
gene is linked to we find multiple
enhancers here's an example of these are
super enhancers so many answers are our
definition enhances us some all hyper
sensitive units right so you can have 30
40 of them in a super enhancer linking
to genes so that's sort of the
distribution so many enhancers linked to
a gene each enhancer can often linked to
multiple genes of course an exponential
distribution but sometimes an answer can
link to up ten genes and there's a nice
distance distribution which supports
sort of what you also see in high C data
and so on yeah
but then after that we can get links
between individual and answers and gene
so this is based on that final statistic
okay the key point is that the energy
network is highly connected fifty-six
percent of the links are specific to one
lineage I think was Muslim interesting
is even though half of the predicted
links are within 50 50 kb of each other
only one-third are actually linked to
the nearest gene okay so that's pretty
interesting so many of them actually
skip the nearest you I think others have
also found this in in other other kinds
of prediction methods I'll skip this
slide was just showing you an example of
example an e qtr idea that skips the
nearest gene the two nearest jeans and
goes all the way to this this particular
gene right and they are we have a link
that supports the CQ dl quite nicely I'm
since I'm running out i'm going to skip
this part and just jump to something
more interesting which is how we can use
these modules to actually info target
genes of non-coding variants so you know
somebody asks a question about whether
it was how does it compare to the
nearest gene linking so you can take an
answer and link into the nearest gene so
the enhancer may contain a non-coding
variant right 4G was variant and link it
to its nearest gene was this link it to
a gene that V predict as being at the
target of that an answer and so you'll
notice that if you then take those jeans
and you do go in richmond's you've done
this for almost 100 gr studies if you
look at the overall some of the Q values
of the of the boat arms right you'll
notice that the linking method actually
gives you better cue values than the
nearest gene method so overall there is
a better pathway enrichment when you use
our links then make the assumption of
nearest gene now to three case studies
real quick the first is a colorectal
cancer so we had a nice geosphere set
for colorectal cancer from the gecko
consortium so we just take all the top
geo snips the p-value less than 10 to
the minus 5 we expand this list because
these are tagged sniffs we expand them
in LD using an Oscar or point eight then
use find all enhancers that overlap any
of these these snips the slip sonality
we link them to the genes using our
links that we predict in crc specific
tissues or colon rectal mucosa and so on
when we do this starting with uh with
almost 5,000 snips because we use a
pretty relaxed p-value we're not only
looking at the genome-wide significant
hit hit list we end up with only 76
jeans and and these are actually a
really nice list of genes many of them
lavin genes and so on very well known to
be associated with colorectal cancer and
in fact if you take those jeans and run
them through go enrichment we pick up a
smashing link tgf-beta intagram pretty
well known to have important roles in
colorectal cancer here's a nice example
of also how we can do this for HDL
cholesterol here's the snip and you'll
notice how the the predicted link jumps
the two nearest jeans bud 13 and ZN f 2
59 and this enhancers is predicted to
link to all the ape o fo a a [ __ ] a PO
jeans and those genes have been known to
actually be involved in HDL cholesterol
lipid metabolism and the last case study
is to do with ulcerative colitis so this
is a long we'll association it's it has
a pretty nice p value and it's
potentially a causal step based on this
pics probability so the snip has been
potentially linked as being causal for
you also do colitis but the target gene
has not been identified so far and what
we find is in this case it of course it
seems to link to the nearest gene but it
is 50k be at least 50 kb of a and this
gene in fact does not have an important
role sort of in some kind of membrane
protein it's specifically active in
intestinal cells and so we have a cell
type of target cell type we have a
target gene and a target a causal
targets snip so just to give you a few
examples of how we are able to link
these use the links to essentially info
tissue-specific of a non-coding variant
and also the target genes associated
with it yeah so i'll just end there and
stay
it briefly that we have an all-pro
holistic model for linking an ancestor
genes and unsupervised and expression
dynamics we get pretty high resolution
predictions which are validated by
expand adhere to some extent B&S is a
pretty important for explaining side by
specific regulation I skip these slides
but we find multiple genes are often
regulated by more than one enhancer and
often different ones in different cell
types so very linear specific linking
majority of an answers actually do not
we do not find them looping to the
nearest promoters and I skip this slide
as well but we find and hasn't promoters
to be enriched for transcription factor
motifs that are known to have strong
protein-protein interactions so that
would be one mechanism by which the
looping happens and the links are
predictive of target genes and pathways
affected by non-coding variants so just
stop there thank John wrong for building
these models Payton did some of the
analysis for the disease variants and
this was original collaboration with
with Maroulis Thanks questions okay this
keeps genes of the expressed yes
I showed you the example of ya ready are
so this is buck 13 right it's in fact
ubiquitously expressed in all the cell
types yours the enhancer you can see is
very specific to liver fg2 and fetal
into stein classical it issues
associated with lipid metabolism here's
the promoter of a piece APIs III also
perfectly coordinated activity right and
you can see it's again very lineage
tissue-specific it's not the classical
linear activation the correlation matrix
like linear or Spearman will feel pretty
miserably or and and so you want some of
these kind of metrics that capture on
off like activity yeah how do you act so
there's a lot of you know tissue
specificity that you're finding here but
have you actually tested so have you
taken a cell line where you expect this
enhancer to be active and one where you
expect it to not be active and actually
done the crisper experiment so yeah
we've just we've just finished with
those with a collaborator I don't have
an answer for you yet but you'll see
let's take both of this